you know we're in a war in Iraq we've
been in this war it kinda ended then we
started it again then we went to Syria
we didn't get congressional
authorization for that nobody thoughts
about that I talked about it but nobody
else does and now in the city of Erbil
which is about 30 miles away basically
from where all this crazy Isis stuff is
happening something really really
bizarre is happening and we've got a
couple images that looks like a mouse
doesn't it does it looks like the White
House invasion does that look like a
Beverly Perry White House they are
literally building a replica of the
White House this is one this is one of
many many giant villas that they're
building this is literally 30 miles from
the worst of the warzone that's going on
over there but there's a lot of money
happening why are they doing it so money
brings were throw a couple of the images
back up real quick so I can give you
some more info uh so many of those are
gated and walled of course and they're
valued at over 600 grand the the replica
of the White House is worth 16 and a
half million dollars uh and it is to
sell yeah so they're gonna sell this
they're calling it the dream city and
it's got dubai-based oh that's right
yeah it's so hideous you know with you
if you pulled that and planted it in
Beverly Hills because the community
would rise up and it would be raised
well they would probably give you some
better landscaping in Beverly Hills but
the reason I want to do the stories I
just think this is kind of interesting
like we see all this horrific stuff
happening there there's no doubt that
there's obviously awful stuff Iraq
basically isn't even a state anymore um
and yet somehow 30 miles from the
epicenter of all this right there's a
millionaire money be a development so
yeah it's literally right it's like an
old ocean everywhere
are there really have good private
schools in the wall there they're really
upset about the the subway that they're
going to be putting underneath this oh
man
because then you bring in the bed ring
and all the people from Isis yeah
what do you make it something like this
way why you guys are going to open this
somebody who builds a mansion 30 miles
away from like the frontlines of Isis is
probably not very concerned with Isis
which i think is probably the most
problematic thing about that because
they there encodes for that I don't know
I mean you know you gotta wonder like
will we be offended if someone blows
this up like sort of as a as like and a
kind of additional a you know an effigy
also right mean it was like aren't they
basically begging for that thing to be
blown up like it's just it's like
telling it like it's taunting I think
it's a bit of taunting yeah is it sort
of like look we can do this as well you
know or maybe they're just really big
fans at Jeff Goldblum and Independence
Day they're doing it ended well they are
making independence they're doing this
is actually a set piece I never saw in
the second thing you never say
independence it looks so stupid to me um
are you guys when I saw the alright guys
yes aren't your idiot sorry John so mean
to him wow he got Ari on it like so
loudly in my microphone I'm so sorry
that's a person you've apologized like
eight times look that's your that's
right can he be apologizing Oh does
anything about Iraq or any of this stuff
surprise you guys anymore like you know
you mean we the war wrapped up then it
started again then it crossed borders
then we know buddy talked about Isis if
you look at a year ago now you look at
every CNN piece nobody had ever even
heard of Isis so like does anything so
when you see a replica white house going
up even though I was surprised for 10
seconds that I was like ah at this point
not none of this [ __ ] surprises me I
mean it I know we're not talking about
this today it's not on the on the roster
but with those school kids killed mm-hmm
in Pakistan I mean what kind of a mind
decides that this is a viable action to
take yeah none of this [ __ ] surprises me
and it's horrifying I know that building
these homes is not horrifying and that's
way but it's completely it's as a logic
I know but right that's what I mean so
obviously there's no comparison 240 kids
being killed in Pakistan to this but
that's what I mean like there's so much
going on at once it's it's like I can't
even wrap my brain around yeah how do
you try to wrap your ring your brain
around this stuff like a lot of alcohol
generally speaking you know I mean
honestly I think the best thing that you
could ever do is to turn off the news
and just not pay attention for a while
because if you do I think like probably
like we are news junkies you know if
you're if you're in it all the time it
is just constant depression I know but
what I understand that but why is it
better to like not know I don't know
that it's necessarily better to not know
from a like humanitarian standpoint but
just from like a person's like mental
stability standpoint save yourself
well if you want the if you want the
answer to Andy's point I did a very deep
philosophical piece on this that we just
recorded yesterday with Kelly Carlin
about how you deal with the news and how
it affects your spirit and how much you
should put into it
so we'll annotate to that you can check
that out and let's move on